hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga today I'm just here to talk a
little bit about a series that I am
particularly excited for in the upcoming
summer season which is dr. Stern and it
officially begins airing on the 5th of
July so is still a while away if you
have not already heard of this property
I would like to put it on your radar now
and I'll start by giving the synopsis
which goes a little something like this
one fateful day all the humanity was
petrified
by a blinding flash of light after
several millennia high school but I'd
you awakens and finds himself lost in a
world of statues however he's not alone
his science loving friend sank who's
been up and running for a few months and
he's got a grand plan in mind to
kick-start civilization with the power
of science so I've been reading dr.
Stein for quite some time now and seeing
the previews for the anime adaptation
here have me pretty pumped now what I'll
say from the outset is that this series
is pretty much just pure fun it doesn't
have too many overly serious plot
elements to it in fact if you're
familiar with shokugeki no souma or food
wars which ever you prefer to say then
I'd very much equate it to that except
instead of cooking we're focusing on
science in general but honestly I don't
think that comparison quite does dr.
stone justice because when you take a
step back from it you realize that its
scope is just so massive as its
characters are charged with the mission
of restoring an entire human history's
worth of technological advances and they
have to do so from a literal Stone Edge
so I guess what I'm trying to say is
that it has a feeling of progress that
food was is very much lacking you know
every innovation opens up a door for 10
other future innovations and at certain
points in the series you look back on
the beginning and just go
we've been on an incredible journey and
some of the things that they make in the
series are guaranteed to blow your mind
on a regular basis which really is the
wonder of science I guess now during my
schooling period I was one of those kids
who didn't really pay much attention
during any for science except for
biology although admittedly only because
my teacher was she was pretty hard so I
wasn't sure how much interest I'd have
in doctor stone before picking it up and
if any of you are in a similar position
let me just tell you that this series
showcases science in such a brilliant
and fanciful manner it's still
maintaining a very solid grounding and
even makes things as simple as possible
for the reader to understand whilst not
talking down to them and that's a
problem I thought I would initially have
with its protagonists ank-ooo he is the
scientific genius / time capsule that
makes the entire series work and reading
the first couple of chapters I was very
afraid that he was going to be kind of
like your standard arrogant genius stick
but despite his frankly absurd
intelligence the series does an Incred
job of making him relatable approachable
and very easy to root for and
interestingly in the anime adaptation
he's going to be voiced by yusuke
kobayashi
is probably best known for performing
subaru from re0 and i associate his
voice very strongly with that character
so it's going to be really interesting
to hear him play such a radically
different role in speaking of radically
different roles doctor Stern also
features a pretty incredible supporting
cast all of whom have their own
particular skills a greatly assists the
mission of restoring science to the
staring world many of whom aren't even
featured in the trailers but once again
I'll draw the food Wiles comparison by
stating that it really is an ensemble
series and the auxilary characters are a
major part of what makes it so much fun
to read and I'm sure to watch as well
although if I had one negative that
should probably be flagged before
watching it's that many of the
characters in my opinion can be a bit
ropey like each of them will have strong
core ideas or beliefs but if you're
looking for anything with a bit more
depth or subtlety you won't find that
and dr. stein because after spending
about a minute with each character
you'll know what they're about instantly
and with a few notable exceptions they
they won't be changing I'd also argue
that it isn't necessarily a bad thing
though because these trophy and
archetypal characters do really allow
the core theme of the show to shine by
acting as a simplistic juxtaposition
some of the science can already be
complicated enough as it is so I think
having simple characters really helps in
regards to inviting the audience into a
topic that by and large would generally
poor and confuse them not only that but
their energy makes whatever science
they're exploring at the time just so
much fun to learn about and even though
I've probably retained a minuscule
amount of what has actually been taught
in the series it does at least give you
the illusion of feeling smarter
afterwards now if anything I'd say that
dr. stone is going to be an even more
incredible experience to watch because
as much as I love the manga there are
periods of huge science the exposition
that I think will really benefit from an
animated medium it's a moving diagrams
and a wonderful vocal performance to go
along with them now with all of this in
mind the only way I think the show could
really fail is if it is handed over to a
poor production company and dr. stone
has been put in the hands of TMS
entertainment and if you're not familiar
with them they are one of the oldest
anime studios in existence having
produced some incredible classics such
as Akira and Lupin the third but moving
into the more modern era they do have
some experience in long-running Shonen
having produced d.gray-man which is
pretty great for its time and even more
recently megalo box so I'm not
particularly worried about dr. stone
from an animation perspective at all and
everything we've seen in the preview so
far look wonderfully schmack and now I
suppose I should be careful not to over
rate the series too much and if you
spend any amount of time looking up
towards CERN on the Internet at all you
probably come across a lot of talk about
the potential
dr. stone to become one of the new-age
big three I mean if such a thing really
exists anymore it's more like the big
one now now I love this series but I
really don't quite know about that it's
a pretty big call to make but I might
not be able to see it that way because
of how unconventional dr. stone is for a
shounen series I mean the undisputed
champions of Shonen have always been
battle manga and that is not dr. stein
if you're looking for an action focus
series this isn't really going to do it
for you so I don't know if that is put a
glass ceiling on dr. stone but it does
still have potential I also have to
acknowledge that we're barely over 100
chapters into it and thinking back on
where world-changing series like one
piece were at 100 chapters in I probably
wouldn't have gone so far as to label it
a future member of the big three either
I mean it was a fantastic story no but
one piece had an awfully long way to go
to reach his full potential and it's
arguably still on its journey over two
decades in and that could be dr. Stein
you know when you're trying to condense
more or less the entirety of human
technological innovation into a singular
experience you've got a lot to play with
in a near infinite amount of directions
that the series could be taken and I
mean who's to say that it would simply
stop when or if humanity is restored why
not keep pushing science beyond what we
know and getting into some true
innovation and yes I know I'm probably
going in a wild tangent here so let's
wrap this up before I go too much
further but my overall point is that I
think the series very much deserves your
attention it's fun
fresh and I highly recommend you all
check it out when it begins airing on
the fifth of July but that pretty much
does it for this short rambling
discussion thing on why I think you
should watch dr. stone if you enjoyed
this video when the content this channel
produced in general and please do
consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
plot this channel an incredible amount
if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on dr. Stein this has been
the New World review and I'll see you
next time
you
[Music]